[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] em
[Music]
oh boy
it's hump day
[Music]
oh and do we have a lot of news this
morning
yesterday's hearing but also news
dropping
continues to drop
not just about republicans and traders
like ron johnson but we get new news
about this um rusty bowers i just have
been really reading a
daily beast article about a statement
that he made to the associated press
so we will get to that and
maybe that should be my [ __ ]
monologue here holy [ __ ] i was going to
say all kinds of great things about
rusty today
and i just had my mind changed about
rusty
because i we talked yesterday on the
hearing broadcast
to jessica denson you guys know jessica
will play a video today
of her response and reaction to
miss moss
and her mother
giving their testimony live and recorded
testimony in the hearing yesterday in
the second panel of the witnesses
jessica denson gave her
response emotional response yesterday
but we also talked about rusty bowers
and how he
invoked his faith today the
the title of the show is separation of
church and state
and here we have faithful rusty bowers
who invokes his faith
into his testimony um talks about how
the the trump campaign
the trump team trump himself pressured
him into breaking
the sacred oath as he called it not just
to the government but to god is how he
kind of framed it up
as part of his religious belief his
faith as it were
he tells the associated press that he
would vote for trump in 2024
folks it's a [ __ ] disease
it's a disease
rusty bowers gave very compelling
testimony i actually thought yesterday
the saddest testimony came from mrs moss
when she talked about she's a normal
election worker
she wanted to serve
the government she wanted to serve the
people
by participating in our democracy in a
way that that got to the the most sacred
right we have
the thing that makes us a [ __ ]
democracy
that her ancestors
didn't have the right to
that was the saddest
darkest part of the testimony but the
most compelling
testimony against trump and his allies
where they have the most criminal
liability in my opinion i'm no lawyer
i'm no judge but it seems that way
was when rusty bowers took to mike
when he was the first witness
he's the arizona speaker of the house
republican
trump gave a statement right before we
watched it adam shift read the statement
the threat it was a [ __ ] threat from
trump
saying
this guy's lying he's lying under oath
he's lying because trump
said
in his statement
that arizona house speaker rusty bowers
told him that it was rigged
and rusty bowers under oath said not
only have i not told that [ __ ]
that it's rigged i i haven't told anyone
that it's rigged because it wasn't
rigged
he's a dumb son of a [ __ ]
and he threatened my family and he
pressured me he pressured my attorneys
they wouldn't give up they were trying
to convince me to break my sacred oath
to the people who elected me
he acted if democracy was sacred in that
moment
and as soon as he left the room as soon
as he got out of oath in front of a
microphone
rusty bauer says that he would vote for
trump in 2024
folks it's a [ __ ] disease
we watched
as the georgia secretary of state chief
operating officer explained it to us he
explained it to us
in detail that he has family members
family members
who he can't convince
that what they're believing is a sack
full of poor [ __ ]
he even talked about how he's had
attorneys smart attorneys who know the
law and he showed them the evidence one
after the other after the other after
the other unproving
their delusion
and even at the end he says
even when they admit every single
argument that they have is is not
factually correct they still say well in
my heart of hearts
in my heart hearts
it's a disease
fascism is easy
to spread it's easy to catch hold
people who have power who are who
are trying to stop equality and equity
because it feels like oppression to the
privileged
equity inequality feels like oppression
to the privileged
they absolutely can admit
that it's an absolute delusion that it's
nonsense it's ridiculous i mean all the
rhino talk this morning rhino rhino
rhino rhino rhino rhino we go back to
the video of eric greitens kicking down
the door and threatening to kill
rhinos quote unquote
don't take my word for it go watch his
video if you can find it
rusty bowers would vote for trump in
2024 the quote is if he is the nominee
if he was up against biden
i'd vote for him again
says rusty
bowers the guy who went and testified
yesterday
that said that trump pressured him
probably illegally trying to commit
fraud
on rusty bowers
we
we seen him testify to the fact that
jenna ella said yes we have the evidence
and would not provide it
and she is lying she's committing fraud
it's election fraud when she's trying to
pressure
election officials to overturn an
election
and she's claiming
this has to be fraud right
this has to be [ __ ] fraud
how can this not be fraud how can this
not be election fraud
she was using her official capacity
to say she had evidence that she did not
have clearly
or otherwise she would have ponied up
the doe
because rusty bowers testified yesterday
that he would have called a session if
he would have been able to have evidence
of
something nefarious
the things that they were saying a list
of names give me a list of names give me
a list of names
they had no list they were lying they
were defrauding
the house speaker rusty bowers in
arizona to try to overturn an election
even rona mcdaniel admits that she was
part of this [ __ ] state elector
scheme
that the rnc was part of this fraud
they were helping let's fund it yeah
hell let's push it
this is why
we must have separation between church
and state
we must we can not
we cannot have people who in their heart
of hearts believe something
contrary to fact
and logic
running our government
toppling it into a fascist state
because their heart feels like something
get the [ __ ] out of here with that
[ __ ]
it's enough of this garbage
and only we can fix it we still have the
right to vote at this point
at this point because if we are relying
on arizona house speaker rusty bowers to
protect us
and protect our democracy we are [ __ ]
there is something wrong with us
rusty bowers did a service yesterday by
testifying to the truth under oath in
front of the american people
but folks it was close it was close
oh boy was it close because rusty bowers
adhered to his oath then
but still would vote for donald trump
in 2024. now some might say oh well
these these republicans know that
trump's not running in 2024 they know
that
how the [ __ ] do they know what's gonna
happen
how the [ __ ] do you know
you don't know
you don't know what's gonna happen stop
your [ __ ] yapping stop capitulating
to this fascist
who wants to be a dictator you stupid
bastards
tell the associated press no [ __ ]
comment
you're only giving fodder
to the people who want to destroy the
democracy that you say you love rusty
bowers
and yes oh tony you're attacking the guy
who who gave us you goddamn right i am
you god damn right i am rusty bauer
should be called out on the floor for
this this is [ __ ] ridiculous
he's not fit for office obviously
no matter what he's done in the past
statements like this after the testimony
that he gave yesterday
disqualifies him for any public office
anywhere
anywhere
i don't give a [ __ ] which one it is
and he gets no [ __ ] points for me
insanity
when after you give the testimony that
you gave yesterday after the the former
president united states releases a
statement basically threatening you
threatening him you better you better
[ __ ] you better [ __ ] lie you
better [ __ ] lie rusty bowers that's
what trump was telling him in that
[ __ ] letter i don't care what you say
he was threatening him you must tell a
lie in front of the committee
and adam schiff read that letter and
bowers refuted it under oath
and then
and then told the associated press yeah
that guy the guy that just threatened me
that lied that tried to get me to lie
under oath
his last ditch effort to get me to lie
under oath
yeah
i'd still vote for him yeah sure i'd
make him the dictator and king that's
cool by me
it's a [ __ ] disease folks it's a
disease
and we have to inoculate it and the only
way to inoculate it is to vote and to
engage right now
not tomorrow not next week not next
month
not till after the hearings are done no
right [ __ ] now
and the way you engage is you have to be
active with this stuff
you have to be in a conversation with
the people that you know
i mean yeah you need to tweet and send
you know retweet this and get these
videos out there into the universe on
social media because the more eyeballs
the better
but you must engage in person you must
this is this is going to be vitally
important because this year is the most
important election year and as soon as
soon as the polls are closed as soon as
the polls are closed and those ballots
are counted 2024 will be the next most
important election in our country
because they're not gonna stop
they're not gonna quit
rusty bowers is proof
it's proof they won't stop
rusty bowers in front of the american
people tells
the entire country
that donald trump is a [ __ ] liar
he's a fraud he's a phony he's a little
[ __ ]
by putting on a statement while i'm
going to testify
and then he walks out and tells
reporters
sure i'd vote for that guy why not i
like that guy i like that guy that's
cool that's cool
insanity
absolute [ __ ] insanity
and you pack this into a box you're like
how in the [ __ ] is he going to get away
with this on right-wing media
he will
he will they'll say ah yeah he said some
crazy [ __ ]
in that in that unfair hearing of the
unselect committee but rusty bowers
really secretly supports donald trump
because he does
they are willing to trade away our
democracy
for their reign of power
they're willing to trade it away folks
absolutely sell out
the people of this country in our
constitution
so that they can make maintain
the white privilege that they see
as being oppressed because of quality
and equity around the corner
because that's what democracy delivers
over time it's difficult it's hard
democracy is a [ __ ]
it is a [ __ ]
but they see it coming they know what's
coming
that's why they're so easily to sell out
our democracy to authoritarianism
to the despots
to the fascist
so easily willing to sell it out
like eric greitens in missouri who's
gonna kick down doors and kill members
of their own party because they're not
maga enough
and you don't think rusty bauer saw that
commercial and heard what eric greitens
was saying
you don't think he realized what that
statement from the former president in
the united states donald trump who tried
to overthrow our constitution who
pressured him to break his oath to steal
an election
based on fraud
you don't think rusty bowers is a little
scared
of what could happen to him if he
doesn't say yeah sure i'd vote for trump
in my heart of hearts
as gay gabe sterling the chief operating
officer of the secretary of state's
office in georgia said
it's a [ __ ] disease folks it's a
disease we have
and that's why we have to get at this
separation of church and state and we
seen as scotus opinion that's why that
is our headline today but there's tons
of news
there's a ton of news there's a ton of
there's a ton of video clips to get to
here from the news that is happening
so let's go to a break when we come back
we will start the [ __ ] list roundup and
go through the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends
because boy
boy boy oh boy do we have a ton of video
to go through today stick around don't
go anywhere we'll be right back after
this break with tony michaels podcast
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa
don't delay and get your pardon blanket
today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
oh
the
disease of fascism
that has been rotting away at our
democracy for decades
[Music]
inside the ones who are admitting that
the cancer is real
like yeah i'm cool with cancer i mean
you know
that cancer can be good sometimes right
i mean you know if it's the nominee if
they're gonna if they're gonna really
you know push back on this whole
white people are bad brown brown people
good stuff but they're going to push
back on that and really talk about
building a wall and locking up our
political i'm for that i'm for that kind
of cancer on our democracy that's cool
no problem no prob if you're really if
you really want to make sure that rich
people get all the tax breaks in the
middle class get it shoved straight up
their ass well i'm for that kind of
cancer here in this democracy the [ __ ]
out of here with this [ __ ] rusty bowers
you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
i
everyone's about oh tony you're
attacking rusty yeah you [ __ ] ain't
right i am
you goddamn right i am it's
that yesterday he gave some of the most
compelling testimony of crimes
like he's describing the fraud happening
right in front of his face he's like i
mean he was brought to tears almost
talking about how a sacred oath they
were asking him to break his sacred oath
that he took
asking him to
commit sedition
election fraud
because he's like give me the evidence
so like yeah we got it but we just can't
show it to you because you know the dog
ate it or whatever
now whatever we'll we'll get it to you
in two weeks two weeks from now
[Music]
rusty bowers you [ __ ]
oh
jesus
just you can't you can't make this [ __ ]
up folks you can't make this [ __ ] up
uh gabe sanchez will be joining us here
in a few minutes at the bottom of the
hour
i'm gonna let gabe explain he he he
decided on the title this morning so i
want him to go through this scotus um
decision that was made on separation of
church and state but before we do that
and go to gabe sanchez talking about
the separation of church and state let's
start the let's start the shitless
roundup and go through the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends start that
countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the tony
michaels podcast you have reached the
part of the show where we round up all
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
well ron johnson hits the news because
he tried to pass a envelope full of uh
fraudulent state electors to the vice
president of the united states um i
guess and to get him to overturn
there's a lot of ron johnson video that
we got to go through here there's one in
particular where he's acting like he's
on a cell phone and a reporter calls him
out on it's [ __ ] hilarious i'd like
to show you guys that let's make this a
little bigger uh lauren windsor here she
did a video back in september 1st 2021
uh lauren says ron knew trump lost
this is the fraud that is being wrought
on us
is that somehow this [ __ ] won
and they continue to do this nonsense
even though we know it's untrue it's
[ __ ]
again even rusty bowers yesterday
admitted that it was [ __ ]
complete utter fraud that they were
trying to commit on the united states of
america and ronald mcdaniel said yeah we
were trying to help we were trying to
help in that effort the rnc was
officially trying to help but here's ron
johnson talking to lauren windsor and
telling her that he knows trump lost
listen we're just wondering though like
why you were there on january 6th and we
were there outside you know all these
other patriots fighting for our
president
why
because i actually respect the
constitution i respect the states
because that's where elections are
decided i mean they're the ones that
they're the ones that certified the
electoral
each individual state does that i
respect that it's a very dangerous road
to start going down the world that
just a hundred senators can actually
decide to find the election i understand
trust me i understand the frustration
okay well there it is i i don't even
need to play the whole video i'm going
to break gabe's inches and gabe if you
you've seen this video before this is
almost rolled uh when lauren at some
sort of i think it was the state bear or
something that she that was this last
year fall last summer yeah september i
believe yeah yeah um i think it was at
the state fairs where she caught him
yeah september 1st 2001 is when she
posted this video so august sometime in
august probably is when she recorded
this um over the summer again some sort
of event but she she clearly gets ron
johnson to admit here that yeah yep it's
it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] i mean i
think if you get any of them uh you know
uh in in a place where they feel
comfortable and familiar they're willing
to say whatever they want you know
um and i think that
that you get them uncomfortable they're
willing to pretend to be on a cell phone
right exactly right yeah he's like i can
see your phone it's not on sir no is it
you know it's it's it's totally on it
let's see if i can find that clip that's
hilarious it's hilarious because
here's the thing is they're trying to
avoid the truth that they know
is the truth like even rusty bowers this
[ __ ] man this [ __ ] this
i can't even i can't even tell you
i can't even tell you i was gonna
compliment him today talk about his
testimony how compelling it was and it
is it's still compelling yeah at the
same time you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you
get out under out under oath right
not under oath you get asked a question
by the ap and you're like yeah sure i
would vote for the guy who was trying to
pressure me and to defraud the american
people and the election like what in the
[ __ ] is wrong with you the uh well i
wanted to say yesterday when we were on
the when we were like having the kind of
debrief on the panel but there were so
many things that were talking about and
it was like you know we're jumping all
around but i will say that is the one
thing i was like i guarantee in my mind
i was like i guarantee that these people
but we already knew here's the thing we
already knew that uh
brad raffelsberger is going to was going
to vote you know he skirted around the
answer of like well whoever the nominee
for 2024 to unite us together whether
that's through hatred is really what the
context is there's like does it matter
the context or it doesn't matter the
um
uh the way in which we unite whether
it's through love or hatred or like
coming together it's the fact that we're
united and we can go a forward front to
actually nominate someone and say that
we have a better chance of winning with
this nominee now with that you have to
remember that all of these guys are like
stone
like they are cold-blooded republicans
right
will they will vote red time and time
again and if trump is the nominee they
will 100 put their money down and double
it on the bet well let me let me read
you what he said the follow-up because
he said obviously if his nominee would
vote in it biden and he was up against
biden he would vote against him but he
said
he said this also simply because what he
did the first time
before kovan he makes sure to to throw
that in the quote here was a was good
for our country in my view it was great
and well i i mean the only thing you
knew that was so great for this country
before right i mean he
tried to destroy health care he tried to
destroy healthcare they're good people
they're good very fine people on both
sides right okay well right well i mean
obviously you want to build a fence to
demonize uh mexicans you definitely want
to hold children at the border yeah you
definitely want to have a muslim ban
that's right you don't want you don't
want any kind of migrants but white ones
to our country you don't want to do that
uh you definitely want to give tax
breaks and economic relief to the
richest in this country not the middle
class and for you definitely he likes
that kind of [ __ ] i mean i don't
understand i don't understand it i mean
yeah the other thing is like you
definitely want to put america first by
putting america last right so that
corporations can move their their
resources overseas even though that's
what you said you're going to be right
the other thing that you might want to
do is you want to pressure foreign
governments to attack your political
allies so you can win an election that's
cool too by rusty bowers yeah that's
obviously a good thing i mean you also
just might want to be a person who
cheats on their spouse you know while
they're having a kid and you know can't
turn over the sex 130 000 to a porn star
you know denies this and then you know
tells that you want to grab someone by
the [ __ ] and everyone says that's just
locker room talk that's just how dudes
be dudes right oh and and also you want
to make sure you you really use charity
money to defraud people and and pocket
that money in your own pocket right
yeah and also you probably want to open
up a fake school a fake school yeah
university or something i mean let's not
forget you definitely want to you know
have some sort of weird sexual
relationship will they won't they
situation with your daughter ivanka
i don't know
i mean it's like this is the [ __ ] they
love american home values that's exactly
what he's saying though he's like all
that stuff all that stuff that's people
that was good
he was like look look
that was good the guy tried to kill me
okay the people tried to threaten my
homes
my daughter who is a widow
you know
like all these people
came in he was dying she was dying oh
yeah she was she was dying in that one
and was the other guy with yes she was
right it was
when they were when they were
threatening her right it's it's insanity
it's insanity it's well i mean like the
whole testimony you hear it yesterday
and you're like holy [ __ ] this is
terrible like to hear these things that
these people these trump supporters who
are domestic terrorists are willing to
take action against their own kind
they're republicans because they said
hey
the facts are the facts and i'm sorry
but your feelings don't matter and they
said you know i feel you do matter and
you're better so much that i'm gonna
threaten your life and i'm gonna show up
to your house and i'm gonna and i'm
going to cause domestic terror in your
neighborhood right and your family
and then they go okay now granted with
all that being said guys i will still
vote for the guy
right exactly well here here is ron
johnson a trump sycophant and a putin's
puppet here um gonna be asked
a question about an envelope that was
given to his office to to
expedite the delivery to the vice
president have you ever heard of this
before
someone going to a senator to make sure
that a vice president gets an envelope
without it being checked like i don't
know what's in it hell you know the
anthrax was be i was way beyond me i had
no idea i had no idea what was in the
symbol
i may have died on the journey to him
but i got the letter to him like this is
a [ __ ] civil war and it's like i do
declare i'll give this letter in my
blood i'll
sacrifice my life and then the best part
is he's like oh my staff it's totally
the coffee the coffee boy or the coffee
girl yeah of course of course the coffee
girl i don't know who that is on my
staff that went oh jesus but listen
watch this video this just shows you how
[ __ ] weak and cowardly these pieces
of [ __ ] are he can't he can't even act
like he's not going to answer a question
he has to pretend he's on his phone
i know because he's such a [ __ ] kid
we've all we've all done this too we've
all done this like put up the phone or
or it might as well check your voicemail
like at least get the phone going i
don't know
i'll just ignore a [ __ ] i'll
just ignore a [ __ ] and that's
what ron johnson can do here is just
ignore [ __ ] right but he's so
weak watch know about what your chief of
staff was doing with the alternate
slates of the doctors
no you're not i can see your phone
i can see your screen no you're not
no you're not
no you're not no you're not like it's
that moment it's that moment in uh like
in high school or grade school when
you're like oh shoot we're walking both
the same way and you're like oh this is
so weird you know like you already said
goodbye and you're trying to avoid this
person and you're like oh crazy i just
got a text and it's like why so much
exposition to tell someone that's like i
don't want to talk to you right like i'm
on the phone i'm talking to this person
they're very important they have a lot
to say uh they need to inform me about
how i left my lunch in the fridge you
know it's like right you know they're
gonna go into detail to avoid the person
be like the fact you're giving the fact
that you're doing this makes it seem
like
there's something to hide here right
right well i mean obviously there's
something high with ron johnson and
these all these republicans are trying
to hide something and we we saw
yesterday with this testimony from
bowers himself what they're trying to
hide because because we know about the
rattlesburger cult that's been released
for a long time we know we know the
pressure that they put on the georgia
officials because of that evidence
that's been out in the public because
trump lied about it and raptors burgers
like no here's the evidence like
before january 6 even happened
do you remember that what happened was
is the call happened week
a week before january 6th yeah and he
recorded the phone call trump
i tweeted i think is what it was
he tweeted that raptors burger said it
was stolen right and raptors burgers
like no i didn't here's the phone call
because rather's burger knew what was
happening because it was happening all
around the country right even with the
rusty bowers because yesterday we
watched adam schiff read a threat from
the former president united states in
real time he threatened him in real time
he basically said in his statement you
better [ __ ] lie you better you better
lie and you better tell them this
well i mean it's un totally unsurprising
right you look at the guy who who sent
out a release statement and said hey
look pence and i talked and pence
totally agrees with me and pence is like
no i didn't where what the [ __ ] are you
talking about right so they knew he was
going to do all this right he knew he
knew they would talk he would say i
talked to him they could confirm that
they talked and he would say yes this is
what happened that's why rather burger
recorded the [ __ ] it's like an
hour-long call or something yeah
and they played parts of it yesterday
during the hearing the most
the most threatening parts were trump
is obviously threatening that either you
do this or there'll be consequences and
i'm the one who's going to dole out the
contract i mean just find me 11 000
votes give me a break tony right it's
ridiculous it's ridiculous yeah but
here's rusty bowers admitting that jenna
ellis
and rudy giuliani
were trying to get him to break his oath
based on fraud and he knew it was fraud
because he even admitted i asked him
time and time and time and time give me
a list of names give me a list of names
give me let's see evidence yeah and
they're like yeah we got it yeah we got
it yeah we got it and they never could
produce it right and he knew he knew in
his heart of hearts
as sterling kind of described there in
his heart of hearts that the evidence
did not exist he knew they were [ __ ]
lying he knew they were committing fraud
and he was not willing to go to a
federal prison
by breaking his oath and committing
election fraud in a federal election he
was not willing to do that
but he's willing to go out and say well
i mean i'd vote for that guy that tried
to get right yeah yeah why not yeah i
mean if he's the president he can pardon
me so what the hell is the difference
what the hell's the difference oh my god
the rhino [ __ ] is is ongoing here is um
john cornyn speaking of [ __ ] [ __ ]
boxes
they're calling him a rhino this morning
and tucker carlson went on to say that
something somehow he's some kind of far
left guy or some [ __ ] do you see that
dr carlson called john cornyn
the guy the guy who is trying to find a
way to take away interracial marriage is
far left
the reason why they're they're after
john cornyn um this morning and today is
because john cornyn stepped up for red
flag laws
uh that was that was the
did you hear that the 13 senators
including mitch mcconnell voted for this
this bipartisan gun reform bill which is
it doesn't doesn't mean it doesn't
doesn't do anything i mean it's a bare
minimum of what what you could expect
that the american people actually want
so like this is the like
just for context they're like this is
the best for four this is the most uh
progressive or however what they said
for form bill since 94. and i'm like in
the grand scheme of things it's not that
progressive it's right we're not
actually i'm glad they did it i i want
to let everyone know
this is not progress this is just the
expectation that we should expect public
officials to do when something hap like
this is the bare minimum of expectation
it really is kind of i mean i'm like
it's enough for them to say look guys we
did something make sure to vote for us
in november hey look we did something to
save your children when in reality you
didn't do anything to really save your
children you just did something to like
you know do fanfare where it's like oh
look we put these red flags and we had
some background checks and we did this
it's like but did you actually address
the systemic problem that's happening no
you didn't think that's the thing but
they didn't even vote for the bill they
just voted to get it to a debate that's
it yeah i would imagine that most of
these 13 aren't even going to vote for
this bill oh no
they're they're going to make sure it
gets it gets 50 and kamala harris can be
the tiebreaker that's what they're going
to make sure of they're going to make
sure that and that's it they just voted
with 13 to make sure that it would break
the filibuster that is it and john
cornyn has become calling far left and
let's listen to this exchange scott
mcfarlane one of our our favorite
reporters there in the hill actually
asked him this question and posted it
what do you make of the pushback from
the the boos in houston and donald trump
calling you a rhino the what in houston
what did he say the booze in houston
yeah the booze and he what does that
mean
and i believe it means that he got a
bunch of
boo
oh oh i thought he meant like booze like
you're drinking
you're getting
he only drinks milk okay well
maybe maybe soy milk i don't know he's
far left he's probably a soy boy yeah
here's here
what scott is trying to get at here is
that you're unpopular in texas now right
like i think that's what he's aiming for
because that's starting to be the
narrative um and you'll see i've also
got a video from the uvalde mayor uh
because i want to talk about ivaldi for
a minute i know you you've had some
interest in this with some of the what
was that videos that you've done on this
um but they're starting to really point
the finger to corn and cruz and abbott
but let's listen to
cornyn's response the the the woker here
cornyn the far left woke her corn in the
[ __ ] his response to trump calling him a
rhino now remember this is after eric
greitens who is a trump-backed senate
candidate in missouri
who is out rhino hunting and he's going
to break down doors and kill rhinos
quote unquote
well if i listen to
all of the critics
i wouldn't get much done um i think uh
those are obviously a very small
fringe of uh of the republican primary
voters somebody uh indicated it was like
four tenths of one percent
of uh people then why do you keep
capitulating to them yeah if it's that
small of a part of your [ __ ] party
why do you why do you keep capitulating
them well it's also like maybe if you
had so many critics there's something to
be said there like maybe there's a i
don't know some sort of like signal
happening here through all the noise of
complaints maybe maybe there's a trend
that's happening and you're like oh man
i'm not really taking this into
perspective i should really reconsider
what i'm thinking like maybe these
critics and constituents of mine have a
point maybe i should actually do my job
and take into consideration
[Music]
you mean like you mean like wait wait
you mean like being a pup publicly i
don't know i mean look it's like maybe
making a legislator someone who's
elected to to represent people are you
kidding me it's out of here
is donald trump fringe um well i just
think you know i i think i'm not
completely
helpful uh it's just uh i think
if we're gonna have no i he is fringe i
just don't want to call in that because
if i call him that he'll definitely
attack me and eric greitens will
definitely come kick down my door
because i will be known as not maga
enough
as eric greitens so alluded to in his
now famous political ad where he wants
to buy samuel ryan
brighton's going to show it to my house
and that's really or or
not eric greitens but an eric greitens
stan someone's gonna show up to my house
because i said something against mega or
trump or whatever and now i have to reap
the the consequences right you know
right well i mean everyone everyone's
saying that like oh eric greitens is
done in missouri no he's not folks that
[ __ ] is going to win that
primary yeah mark my words he's going to
win that primary and john cornyn's
little video here him his response to
rhino is a proof of it well name calling
and blah blah blah and constituents and
and and votes and little percentages and
i don't think that we should compet this
is nonsense
a debate about policy i'm all for that
but i'm not going to engage in a in a
game when has john cornyn ever said a
[ __ ] thing about policy yeah give me
a break i'm willing to debate about it
i'm willing to you know but it's all
like it's all fanfare he's like oh look
i'll bring it to the floor so we can
talk about it but i'm not saying i'm
going to vote for it right you know well
that's what he has to say right like he
has to just show that like oh look we
put we presented something forward to
discuss however those leftists those
democrats wanted to change it so we
tracked what you bought where you bought
as if you couldn't already do that
uh everything that you want in terms of
a gun so it's these people like they're
gonna like they're like oh yeah look uh
i i made the effort
to bring it forward right everyone's
complaining about the filibuster and all
this stuff well i let us debate about it
i let us give everyone give their two
cents but in the time between when i
said yeah we should bring it forward and
when we voted on it those leftists man
they [ __ ] came after you guys and so
i was here to defend you so i wasn't
willing to accept that bill as its
current state that's what they're going
to say right that's how they're going to
use it when they vote against it well
yeah i mean they always they always
[ __ ] it's always nonsense well
speaking of nonsense and horseshit do
you remember the mayor of vivaldi in the
famous video
where beto auroric approaches the how
dare you yeah you sumbitch how dare you
yeah were you sure to be braver right
that was the guy that was the guy with
the walker yeah he was he's kind of how
dare you i barely get up from my desk
right we'd have to do a job well now
he's being pressured of what's happening
with uvalde because he is the mayor in
that city look at that yeah he's like
almost it's almost like an elected
official
should have to be held accountable for
something that happens especially if
they try to cover uh because that's what
we're seeing with ivaldi now we now know
uh from recent reports that the police
waited an hour before they even
approached the door to see if it was
unlocked the um the the chief of police
at the time which i believe he's a
councilman now um and he's trying to get
a leave of absence um and the reason why
is because he doesn't want to be seen in
public because
he's under heavy scrutiny for the
decisions that he made that day at the u
right
at rob elementary in uvalde but here is
the mayor pointing the finger not not at
himself
of course listen to who he points the
finger at these are the same
[ __ ] listen if you go back and
you watch the video better roark
this is the guy standing on the stage
with these [ __ ] listen to what
he says here how herald was in that room
with me
tracy king was in that room with me
senator cruz senator corn i didn't even
tell you who the dps officer that gave
the damn briefing to the governor not me
not me at all because i didn't have any
information because they wouldn't give
me any information
i'm just as frustrated maybe not as
frustrated as the families have lost
their loved ones and there's there's the
image of this uh mayor don mclaughlin i
think is this guy's a [ __ ] drunk
well he kind of he kind of looks like
this guy this guy is having uh the worst
of days right now health wise i
guarantee this guy is [ __ ] himself
well i mean there's there's cause that
he is not gonna be the mayor for much
longer
also i'm going to show you a video of
how this chief of police who is now a
councilman
is probably not going to be a councilman
for much longer um i don't know what
kind of accountability we're going to
get and what kind of evidence is going
to come out of uvaldi but it just seems
lie after lie after lie is piled up in
the evidence here and here's this guy
going i didn't know any of this stuff i
mean he literally is saying i didn't say
anything it wasn't me
um there's there seems to be criminal
liability here and even uh civil
liability here and they're trying to uh
skirt that and that's what he's trying
to do but listen to the remainder of who
he blames but it pisses me off that i
can't give you answers or can't get you
answers
so like i said i don't know any
allegiance to anybody i'm turned out as
mayor when i get through and i don't
want to seek political office again so i
don't any any of these elected officials
not a damn thing
and so i'm telling you now while you're
here on the president though they're
seeing it i'm not covering up for
anybody
if you're guilty we're going to throw it
out there you want to cover up we're
going to throw it out there so there is
a cover-up apparently yeah i mean i mean
that's what i mean oh tony tony tony
water is wet man right that's what
that's like this isn't this like when
they
you know like that day look look every
single day i mean just
just this weekend saturday i sent you an
article about how they were saying that
oh actually they didn't even try to open
the doors
inside the school when they went in
right well yeah well because the the the
news story which which is the
frustrating part about this is they keep
moving the goal post and we're talking
about the lives of 19 children and and
two teachers that the people of uvalde
right want to know what the [ __ ]
happened it's just it's a simple
question they want to know what happened
[ __ ] happened and and they keep lying
and if they would have just told the
truth in the beginning which may be the
truth is something they cannot tell
right right that that might that may be
what we discussed i mean even if they
said hey look we don't know
but we are
looking through it right now
instead of so look it it would seem that
we we uh he came in through a door the
door was open okay it turns out the door
was locked okay there was a cop that
confronted him outside nope turns out
there wasn't a catholic in front of him
okay so during those 78 to 90 minutes uh
we did go in okay well actually we did
go in but it was only to get our kids
okay but we did go in but we didn't open
those doors and those doors that we
wanted to open were unlocked but we
couldn't actually do it because we were
afraid for our lives because even though
we were trained and we had the actual
military weaponry and the shields and
yeah because there's video evidence of
them having shields right inside the
school and not doing anything like
ballistic shields like you have things
that are made for this situation you
have been trained explicitly for this
situation and what did you do
you stood outside and the only people
you actually put in cuffs the only
people you actually detained were the
parents of the children that were being
slaughtered that were that were willing
to risk their own life to save their own
children and you said
you wouldn't
who wouldn't risk your life to say save
a bunch of children to be ripped apart
right by a semi-automatic war machine
well these police and the police chief
and here is a video
of um and and i let's i forget her name
i'll tell you the name after the video
but this this lady lives just a few
doors down from rob elementary not far
away she could probably hear the shots
being fired right um
and she goes to the council meeting
because apparently this uh this chief of
police his former chief of police who is
now a councilman uh who was apparently
you know again we don't know what the
truth is because they keep [ __ ] lying
apparently he was the the commander on
scene right um and he was looking for
keys is what they're saying master keys
is what they're saying right now which
and honesty i think that's a bunch of
[ __ ] because they supposedly had
this this thing where they were
practicing inside that school you think
they would know the location of those
keys as part of their protocol but
anyway
or that you'd be trained to say hey look
we don't have the [ __ ] master key how
do we get into the room right if you're
going to tell me that there wasn't some
contingency plan to say we don't have
the keys how do we get in oh actually
uh in order to undo this door or remove
this lock or get in or whatever this is
what you would do like there is probably
a protocol in place not just hey anyone
seen the janitor oh he's in the room oh
[ __ ] well we'll just wait outside right
like yeah we'll stand here and wait for
someone to bring us the key yeah the
other the other craziest part about that
is that that i've been saying this for a
long time these [ __ ] these [ __ ] um
active shooter drills and all this [ __ ]
doesn't work that's all [ __ ] it does
they don't work you're training shooters
you're you're you're not doing the thing
that you can do to make sure that lives
are safe you need to stop that nonsense
that that that training and all that i
believe that this is proof just like
good guy bad guy [ __ ] doesn't exist that
that training is not working that we
actually need to get at the heart of the
problem which is the [ __ ] gun but
listen to this lady here talk about how
they're trying they're trying what the
um
the new councilman the previous uh chief
of police who was the commander on duty
um apparently at the during the shooting
in uvalde at robb elementary he's trying
to seek a a leave of absence
and he hasn't even hardly taken his seat
yet and listened to her cry here to what
can happen and telling the council get
rid of his ass and she kind of finds a
loophole listen to this
two doors down from rob elementary
i was there the day of the shooting
so thank you for um changing exactly
what i was going to say mr mayor um
because you said we don't have the power
to fire him
let me give you a simple out you can
remove him
because he's going to vacate his seat so
article or your agenda number six is a
decision on whether or not to give him a
leave of absence why the hell would you
so there she's he's asking for a leave
of absence and she's saying why would
you do that now she's going to get to
the heart of how how they can oust him
um by him vacating his seat because he
needs a leave of absence here quote
unquote so he's going to vacate rather
they grant him the official leave of
absence or not
let him miss
three meetings he's my councilman
let him miss three
don't waste any more time on him
i know you probably all have a
relationship with him i don't know him
he's my councilman i'm sitting in a
district right now that no councilman
has come to my door to say hey how you
doing
there's 21 22 lives that were lost
we all know why
the investigation is going to come in
and tell us all why what we can do
better what you can do right now is not
give him if he requested it a leave of
absence don't give him an out we don't
want him we want him out
we wanted to do a recall a recall
petition right we had so much enthusiasm
in it right away 162 votes we need 25
right
but we can't because he hasn't been in
his seat for eight months that's bs
so then we thought how do we change the
charger well it's already been amended
we can't do it for another two years but
you can do something
right now tonight and not table whether
you're going to decide to give him that
leave of absence i implore you
do not give him that leave of absence
i've heard you guys
and this bothers me a whole lot i had an
idea when i came in here
i was gonna do a very short
grant leave of absence so that we had
vote on it over and over and over
so you guys wouldn't see him
but i don't need to talk a whole lot
more
i make a motion we do not grant the
leave of absence for councilman
damn
um there's democracy right there in
front of you and if you don't think that
your voice matters if you don't think
that that you can change minds um it's
possible now it's a it's a [ __ ]
with some of these fascists running
around but you can change minds you can
you have to go get engaged
it is super important her name um
uh her name the
the
the the citizen who spoke there vivaldi
who lives just a few doors down
from the
uh
from the rob elementary her name is kim
hammond rex
posted her name so um kim here is a hero
um this is what this is what a true
person who's speaking truth to power
looks like um not not not an elected
official calling out another elected
official this is an average citizen
standing standing at a microphone giving
the best evidence she can giving the
most compelling argument of why
politicians that are elected elected
officials should or should not do
something and they listened and they
listened and now they're not going to do
it every time right right right but yeah
i mean like you know this is a situation
where like this is this is a situation
that is unfortunately a travesty right a
lot of you know these 19 children and
two adults were slaughtered by a person
that was able to easily get an ar-15 at
their 18th birthday and
they're just it's a simple it's just a
simple request hey can you guys not put
this person in power like he doesn't
represent us he's not listening but also
there's much
there's obviously a much bigger story
going on which is this cover-up you guys
say one thing and then now we find out
the doors weren't actually locked they
were unlocked and despite that
like now like every time like you know i
joked about it last week i was like oh
they're going to tell us that there were
never doors that existed in the first
place so they're going to say we could
have never gone in right right but like
i joke but there is there is some
serious like there is some reality to
that which is like every time they keep
changing the story about the doors and
this and that and like then you find out
the doors were unlocked so they could
have gone in and they had the problem
it's the same it was the same thing with
the back door they said it was propped
open and then it wasn't propped open
right it just continues to be one thing
after another um i mean it's just yeah
they're just continuing to blame anyone
but themselves you know they're
unwilling to look in the mirror and go
oh man maybe we [ __ ] up right well and
we see the people you've already putting
pressure on their local politicians and
the local elected officials to get to
the heart of this uh speaking of local
officials i don't mean to switch too
many gears here but um you know the
transitions here but i said what the
actual [ __ ] is this now this is a shot
oh my god this is this is uh uh eric
it's it's eric adams right and then yep
eric adams yeah he's the new mayor of
new york he's a former
uh police officer now you see the
bulldozer here it's like a d9 right and
and i i actually said what the what the
actual [ __ ] is this people were smart
this morning they're like we know it's
hump day tony but this is a bulldozer
running over dirt bikes i can [ __ ]
read it says bulldozer crushing illegal
dirt bikes
i can read folks i know what dirt bikes
are i know this is a d9 bulldozer a cat
but here's the thing
what i'm asking is why does this video
even exist and the thing that gets me
the most in this video is the eric adams
waving the checkered flag obviously
there is a problem in new york city with
atvs on the streets they're very
dangerous i'm sure in a city i come from
the country they're dangerous in the
country too but they're not like a
danger to a lot of other people around
because you know you're driving them
like in a in a field or something you
know
not with other cars or people right
zooming in and out you know you know um
but here here
and it seems like not all these are dirt
bikes it seems like some of these are
are actually like people call them
crotch rockets these are motorcycles
right here
so motorcycles can actually be licensed
so i don't know
how dangerous some of these bikes are
some of them are actually dirt bikes or
atvs but some of these bikes are are not
that um but the actual and let me let me
make this bigger here the actual act
of recording this for social media
because here's the thing if atvs and
motorcycles are dangerous and
and they should be allowed on the
streets or in um especially
on the public ways in new york city then
you should just take them off the
streets and they actually have shredders
and have you seen these videos of these
shredders where they put cars and stuff
in and they should oh yeah yeah right
they shred them but this is an obvious
attempt which they probably take what is
le and they probably spent a bunch of
money like scraping this [ __ ] off this
pavement to go put it in a shredder um
so that they could recycle this thing
but watch what this [ __ ] how they
recorded this to destroy these bikes
this is really
i don't know why they're wasting time
doing this
fires up the old d9
here we go
it's kind of fun to watch but i don't
understand why the mayor of new york is
doing this
right
why how much
how much like that how much money that
that's the other thing because they have
made well one is how much money did they
waste on this whole [ __ ] pr stunt but
two how much money could they have made
to sell these things out of state
to sell these in or or in a different
area right like okay you ban them in the
city right
why not sell them within the state
somewhere else right where they are
legal and they're not as dangerous right
and maybe you can make money there's so
much [ __ ] waste that was just created
by this well i mean you could argue that
point but
the real point is why are you doing this
on again
it is it is an attempt by eric adams to
show
you know to chess pound here
of how he's cut back crime in
in the city which really i mean this is
the dumbest thing i've ever seen it's
not really it's it's not the dumbest
thing i've ever seen but it is a very
dumb thing that i've seen today right
i'm sure something else today will show
me that it's even [ __ ] oh yeah we'll
get way dumber today yeah we'll get way
dumber today but this is really dumb
this whole like like i look at this lot
and i'm assuming that those are even
more bikes behind it right well and i
mean again they spent a lot of money
lining these up oh yeah how much time
did it take to take this from like the
impound lot right move it over here line
up this audience because they haven't
it's not like it's not like this is how
the city destroys the bikes and they're
recording it to show it they set this
whole thing up
they spend all kinds of money set this
whole thing up now i have this video now
someone has to pick up all the [ __ ]
small pieces
yeah well yeah they have to scrape this
off like now no one can be like oh hey
you want to dispose of this great we
could ride this to an area and you could
just like because if you if you look
behind the barriers here
you know right there there's more yeah
there's more bikes right and and the
reason why there's more is because this
isn't how they typically destroy them
this is a stunt this is a political
stunt yeah now again i'm sure i'm sure
that it is a valid
argument to take these types are sort of
these types of bikes off the streets and
confiscate them if people aren't willing
to you know legally possess them meaning
that you can't ride them around on the
streets right right
i just don't get the actual theatrics of
this and i guess eric adams is kind of a
a social media [ __ ] it reminds me it
reminds me like lauren bobert or marjory
taylor and you remember the video where
marger taylor green uses this big huge
cannon to shoot a toyota prius you
remember that yeah like why why what the
[ __ ] is the point
i don't know man it's just like
it's one of those [ __ ] it's the same
stupid [ __ ] they love
to [ __ ] make a big like [ __ ] mess
of [ __ ] where they're like i'm gonna
shoot this car or i'm gonna blow up this
i don't know if you remember there was i
forgot who the person was but they were
uh they were shooting um a stack of
papers right or something like that it
was like the bills or something like
that and it was like this is what i'm
gonna do this is what i'm gonna do to
nancy pelosi's bills it's like no you
wouldn't no you wouldn't spend time on
actually creating policy and finding out
what your constituents want instead of
it's a trend
to bring it back to eric greitens like
it was a trend that was moving in that
direction where before they were like oh
this is a representation of something
this is this eric ryan's like nah [ __ ]
that i'm going to say how i'm going to
actually go and i'm going to kill these
[ __ ] well here's the shotgun
here's his text even after what he's the
fascist
[ __ ] theater that he created with
that ad here's what he said afterwards
about the the
the advancement of this uh gun reform
bill in the senate
what he said
text of a new gun confiscation bill was
passed tonight in the senate
which is it just advanced to debate
they didn't want anyone to actually
review the text because this will be one
of the most anti-2a laws ever passed
which is completely utterly
untrue it is a [ __ ] lie
this thing only only gets at the heart
of what people are saying
in the country 80 of the people are
saying look
look we have to
we have to [ __ ]
check people if they're going to get
guns
and there has to be red flaw
red flag laws against i don't know
people like
like a former governor of missouri who
might threaten his wife with violence
and actually create a political ad
talking about killing his political
enemies i don't know maybe like that but
listen to the last sentence here because
this gets to the heart of what he this
is exactly what the [ __ ] he said
you need new senate leadership
instead of weak rhinos who cave to
liberals every time now if you go back
and watch his video and then you take
this sentence to him literally we need
new senate leadership instead of these
weak rhinos
so what is he saying gabe is he saying
the other day that we should that that
you should elect eric greitens and hire
the government and soldiers to go kill
weak rhinos in the senate
or is he saying you should elect him it
is hard to tell yeah it's hard to tell
and i actually i actually tweeted at him
[ __ ] him i said maybe you should go bust
down their doors and confiscate them
rhinos like you son of a [ __ ]
uh i don't want to i don't want to
interrupt you you do have breaking news
so do that and then bring up the tweet
what what do we got uh it's about
january 6th it's about january 6th okay
uh let me let me pull it up here see
what this breaking news is here and then
i'll i'll quickly play the video
[Music]
breaking news it looks like um a tweet
from kyle
cheney here about benny thompson i have
not read this yet uh so this is new to
me news bendy thompson tells us after
thursday the select committee will
resume hearings in july the panel is
reassessing its schedule after
significant new tranches of evidence
have arrived including documentary
footage
nara productions
is it nara do they say nar is it n-a-r-a
i don't know i'm sure that somebody said
yeah probably no i don't know but i mean
like coincide this is i mean if you
think about it we've got all this other
news right we've got jenny thomas emails
does that mean they're canceling
tomorrow's no no no no no no no this is
oh okay they're just extending they're
extending they're saying okay we're
going to do thursday and then we're
going to come back after the holiday to
make sure that we don't lose anyone
right
it's the same
same reason why uh someone when they're
like oh there's a big television event
we're going to just not show our
television show tonight we're going to
bring it on next week so we don't
compete
right but but here here they're clearly
saying that there's just going to be
more hearings based on documentaries we
don't know how many more i mean we
already knew that there were going to
there they had to replace one that was
already there that got canceled because
of the potentially non-existent baby
uh and then that they were going to be
david bender told us yes that there
might be what indic what might seem to
be seven hearings instead of six
remember they were supposed to be eight
before they escaped yeah well they said
six six to eight was going to be the
array yeah so it looks like according to
david bender yesterday he told us that
there's gonna be seven so we have a two
we have two additional hearings after
the fifth hearing that's on thursday
tomorrow
so now it looks like because the the the
timing is too close to january 4th and
maybe people leaving and holidays and
this and that they want to make sure
that we have everyone's attention as
possible right
um
especially you know july 4th it's like
hey look you know
such an important date in our country's
history maybe we should have something
once we get everyone after the fact
let's go to a video that someone posted
what was that um of a recap i want to
play a recap here of of the first second
and third hearing here um that we posted
uh actually might have such posted on
their youtube channel just based on i
mean just based on yesterday's hearing i
could probably do a whole segment but i
will wait after thursday and probably do
another recap of four and five
okay well let's let's watch
the what was that here it's about
six almost seven minutes here so hang
with us let's listen to um gabe's recap
here
of the first two hearings with this is
episode four right or is this episode
three this is episode
four episode four yeah because the first
one is uvaldi the second one was nra the
third one was peter navarro and this is
number four so let's listen to episode
number four of what was that the first
three january 6 series have turned out
to be quite the show we found out that
those around trump didn't believe his
lie of a stolen election trump grifted
250 million dollars from his followers
and apparently the reason trump claimed
he won the election was all thanks to a
drunk rudy giuliani
[Music]
according to nielsen at least 20 million
people tuned in to watch the first night
of the january 6th hearings and just for
perspective that's on par with big
television events like a sunday night
football game and unsurprisingly fox
news chose not to air the hearings they
didn't go to commercial during the first
night i mean can you imagine if sean
hannity had shown the hearing and then
this came up no more crazy people
no more stolen election talk
yes impeachment and 25th amendment are
real
many people will quit we already knew
fox news hosts brian kilmeade laura
ingraham and sean hannity were sexy i
mean uh texting former white house chief
of staff mark meadows to urge trump to
act on january 6th so it makes sense why
none of them would want their viewers to
actually watch the hearings it means
that they would learn the truth for once
and speaking of truth trump was told by
his closest friends and advisors that he
lost the election i made it clear i did
not agree with
the idea of saying the election was
stolen and putting out this stuff which
i told the president was [ __ ] even
trump's own daughter ivanka knew that he
lost i respect attorney general barr
um
so i
accepted what he said was saying i gotta
hand it to liz chaney in the committee i
mean nothing cuts deeper than hearing
your lover i mean a daughter saying or
oath in front of millions that you're a
loser and despite everyone telling trump
that he lost there was one person he
could count on to tell him otherwise a
drunk rudy giuliani
or
just rudy giuliani i guess apparently
everyone knew rudy was intoxicated on
election night except for rudy justless
and a former campaign adviser and man
trying to cosplay as bane jason miller
was there anyone in that conversation
who in your observation had had too much
to drink where giuliani tell me more
about that what was your observation
about his
uh potential intoxication during that
that discussion about
what the president should say uh when
he's addressed the nation on election
night
and the mayor was definitely intoxicated
rudy doesn't need anyone's help
embarrassing himself this is the same
guy that was caught tucking his shirt
into his pants and borat too had melting
hair dye on live tv booked the four
seasons landscaping farted on jen alice
was on the mass singer and literally
married his second cousin
yes he married his second cousin this is
the man who urged trump to prematurely
declare victory on election night
oh boy despite trump's former campaign
manager bill stephen urging trump not to
declare victory prematurely trump
ignored him instead he listened to rudy
who was feeding trump's paranoia and
pushing him to make unsubstantiated
claims about ballot harvesting voting
machine tampering and much more and it
was those election lines that helped the
trump campaign grip 250 million dollars
from its supporters the campaign spammed
supporters with millions of fundraising
emails claiming that the left-wing mob
was undermining the election and urging
them to fight back these emails were
more annoying than those bad luck chain
emails i get from my aunt cheryl
sorry anne cheryl trump promised his
supporters that the money was going to
an election defense fund however
according to a committee investigator
there was no evidence that such a fund
ever existed
instead most of the money went to groups
supporting trump not to fund court
battles the january 6 committee calls
this the big rip-off but i believe a
more appropriate title for this criminal
activity is the big grift now
day
three
was off
to a
slow
start all jokes aside i just want to say
thank you to judge luddig leading up to
january 6 trump was pressuring pence
publicly and privately to reverse the
2020 election trump even used his lawyer
john eastman to pressure pence as well
eastman's theory was that pence could
either reject electoral votes outright
or throw it back to the state
legislators to re-examine
here's the thing though there was no
legal constitutional or historical basis
for this and even though eastman knew
the plan was illegal he still went out
in public and said it was legal pence
repeatedly told trump that he lacked the
constitutional authority to do what
trump wanted but trump wasn't having it
he even went as far as to tell pence he
wouldn't be his friend anymore if he
didn't overturn the election to which
the president says no no no
you don't understand mike you can do
this i don't want to be your friend
anymore if you don't do this trump
sounds like a six-year-old mob boss on
the playground making threats about who
can and can't go to his birthday party
so on january 6 when pence told trump
over the phone that he would not reject
the votes or delay certifying the
results
trump called pence a wimp and a [ __ ]
and it was trump's anger and
disappointment in pence that trump
supporters heard loud and clear during
his january 6 speech if paints came
we're going to drag [ __ ]
through the streets
[Music]
the danger to pence was real as the mob
got about 40 feet away from the vice
president and a confidential informant
from the proud boys told the fbi that if
the group would have found pence
they probably would have killed him man
to be a fly in mike pence's head when
all of this was going down
but even after the ride at the capitol
eastman would not take no for an answer
on overturning the election he called
former white house lawyer eric hirschman
to talk about it i said to him
are you out of your f in mind
right i said i
could i only want to hear two words
coming out of your mouth for now on
orderly transition
now the screamer said i don't want to
hear any other fn words coming out of
your mouth no matter what other than
orderly transition repeat those words to
me
and actually
eventually you said orderly transition
i said good john now i'm going to give
you the best free legal advice you're
ever getting in your life
get a great fn criminal defense lawyer
you're going to need it hold on what was
that get a great fn criminal defense
lawyer you're going to need it shortly
after eastman sent rudy giuliani an
email saying i've decided that i should
be on the pardon list if that is still
in the works all right i hope that we
can all agree that anyone asking for a
pardon has clearly done something wrong
so far the first three hearings have
confirmed that trump knew his claims of
a rigged election were not true but he
still made them anyway and he hasn't
stopped since trump is currently rage
posting about the january 6th hearings
on truth social guys he's demanding
equal time so trump if you're watching
this come on down and claim your equal
time liz cheney and the committee would
love to have you well i'm gabe sanchez
and this has been what was that
[Music]
gabe sanchez with what was that whoa
what was that what what what was that
that's becoming a popular uh little
thing that you got going yeah this is
the what was that yeah it's a you know
it it definitely i mean there's so much
here i will say this there is so much
[ __ ] that is happening the news where
i'm like ah which one do i dedicate my
time to because then it's the whole
thing of like writing the monologue
making the jokes coming up series you
know it's a whole thing so i really have
to decide like what's going to be the
most
potentially evergreen but also like
impactful thing
well
because they they just
everybody's just a pile right he needs
to pop i can do a whole thing probably
on eric adams and his [ __ ] right just
the [ __ ] bike thing thing because i'm
sure i'm sure the story really is is
that eric adams is not doing that great
a job no no probably i mean like no i'm
at the bike thing at the bike thing yeah
yeah well i mean he's being challenged
on the bike thing so they're like well
let's just create a video to show how
tough i am right right
elected official can just do that the
thing
that the people want right like right
like
yesterday 13 republican senators voted
for some of these laws that 80 of
americans want in the senate you just do
that like that that is enough when your
policy pushes towards the thing that
you're wanting where the policy is we
take these atvs off the streets to make
it less dangerous and we just confiscate
these things if you just do that if you
just do that thing and they're not there
then you don't have to [ __ ] create
this this sensational video where you're
you're destroying them with a cat d9 or
something yeah yeah speaking of
sensation and lies and [ __ ] uh you
you remember this guy you know who this
guy is oh yeah the ceo of uh [ __ ] you
know
social oh yeah social too central
two two three two three
right um devin nunes he has something to
say about the select committees now i
don't understand why he's saying this as
the ceo of trump media and technology
group but let's listen with this uh
charade
so
i think what's going to have to happen
here ultimately is if the republicans
are successful in the fall
there's going to be need to be a whole
host of investigations but especially
around
january 6th
and what the government and the biden
administration and the democrats in
congress everything that they've been
doing and even some republicans or
supposed republicans need to look at how
they're doctoring evidence how they're
manipulating people
with this
why is the ceo of a social media company
why is he saying this [ __ ] to sebastian
gorka on whatever trainer tv network by
the way i never tweeted about sebastian
gorka and he blocked me on twitter so
yeah i'm gonna point that out there the
guy's a [ __ ] [ __ ] snowflake no i
caught him i know it's like trump called
pence
yeah grab him by the old [ __ ] yeah
grabbed by the wimp uh they said oh he
called him a winner he may call him a
wimpy call him a [ __ ] yeah he's like i
never saw those guys i never said that
and it's like yeah you did um yeah dude
i don't know man this is the last person
you should ever have talking about
anything this guy was a failure as
someone that was that was uh that was in
as a lawmaker right he tried to sue a
[ __ ] cow or a fake a cow account
uh this guy they were making fun of him
he's for free speech gabe look look look
look this is sexy
okay all i'm saying is it would be nice
if uh wait a second we just wouldn't
talk anymore we gotta tell the audiences
devin nunes who is the ceo of true
social where they claim that there's
free speech over there he is the guy who
sued a twitter account an anonymous
twitter account that was called
devin nunez's
what was it called devin is his cow i
mean i we follow each other uh let me
and he sued because
they were saying bad things about him
you know a guy yeah it's called devin
nunes cow it's at devin cowell devon cow
that's right yeah devon cow and so much
so that when he became the and maybe
that's why he went over to true socials
to make sure there was no social media
accounts there's also
there's also the account that's uh at
noon as alt and it's the devin nunes is
alt mom oh it's okay okay so there's
several of them and yeah yeah and
they're very popular accounts and they
definitely have a voice and they're
using it for good because she sues them
because he's you know well just like
it's nonstop material they're just like
hey look uh we wouldn't make fun of you
for the ridiculous things if you didn't
try to sue a twitter account if you
didn't organize ridiculous right yeah
it's like look you you're a man who
supports the bill of rights right you
know you support the first amendment
right no
no okay i mean i don't want to take it
back to you know lauren bobert earlier
this week or the weekend saying uh you
know you don't have freedom you know you
don't have these rights and it's like oh
boy okay i guess that whole thing bill
of rights was just a made-up thing you
know right well right yeah the other
thing that gets me about devin nunes is
remember when trump first came into
office
he he was the he was the blockade for
the russia collusion right yeah you're
really trying hard uh in the house um to
make sure that there was no talk of
russia collusion right he even was
running back and forth between the white
house but that's the yeah that's the big
thing but speaking of russian collusion
this guy's been in the news ron johnson
um and i guess i don't know
johnson
i don't know that's what i wrote on the
board today i wrote i don't know this is
on the board today i'm not sure who this
guy is next to him
but
what parnez seems to know
leb partner says here this is the same
ron johnson that celebrated independence
day in russia met with sanctioned
russian assets to get job
maybe that's what it is that might be
who it is and spread russian
misinformation he received from
sanctioned um russian asset
on andrei dirkcock dear [ __ ] i don't
know uh in the halls of congress i'm
guessing that's who that is
and he's saying
right what i don't i don't know are you
trying to say it in a russian accent
yeah i'm just trying to give it a little
like oomph you know so it's like andrew
durcock you know well hey hey i'm a
hillbilly my name is andre
i i i'm a hillbilly over here so no no
that's fine i get it you know every once
in a while you say things how you say
them you know the audience the audience
doesn't know this but sometimes uh gable
texts me something and i have no idea
what they're always talking about and i
say speak hillbilly will you please and
i go okay okay okay i'll break it down
speak hillbilly would ya um stop and and
the story is that that
led partners was trying to point out
here is that gop senator ron johnson of
wisconsin wanted to hand deliver
alternative fraudulent electors yeah
vice president mike pence they didn't
they didn't just have alternative facts
man they had alternative electors right
well i mean yeah that that well that was
part of this that was part of this
fraudulent scheme right well when they
showed when they showed that i
completely forgot
the fake elector like
uh paper the ones that they had shown
they're like here's the real one here's
a fake one i completely forgot about it
oh you mean you mean during the hearing
because they did they showed during the
show
they were so shitty weren't they it was
like hey look guys throw this
yeah just like throw this in a word doc
and uh make something make something
happen here and we're gonna have we
gotta have that clip here let's see if
we can it's just one of those things
where it's like um
it was insane to see it when i first saw
it online originally
and then
i was like oh my god you got to be
kidding me
this is so dumb this is insane that
they're they just showed up they're like
look i'm a real elector check out this
paper that was signed by me and also me
but i said it was someone else you know
well it it
it's funny when you see the comparison
i'm trying to see if i can find a clip
here uh oh here here here it is i think
i think here it is um
yeah i think someone i think i think
this might be it this is a clip here um
where they're describing the fake
electors let's listen on november 18th a
lawyer working with the trump campaign
named kenneth cheesebro wrote a memo
arguing that the trump campaign wait
wait what was his name kenneth i know
when they said it yesterday i was like
oh man how people should be writing this
name oh [ __ ] man you can't you can't
make this [ __ ] up like a double
cheeseburger uh extra bacon that's right
and uh two doubles two dots yeah and can
i throw a shake in there as well yeah
right right right maybe some maybe some
nugs you know right we're gonna we're
gonna have some mcnuff kicking nugs
right yeah make nug nugs oh let's see
let's listen kane should organize its
own electors in the swing states that
president trump had lost
the select committee received testimony
that those close to president trump
began planning to organize fake electors
for trump in states that biden won in
the weeks after the election
who do you remember being involved in
those early discussions around the
thanksgiving time
regarding having alternate electors meet
mr giuliani
several mr giuliani's associates mr
meadows
um
i'm trying to see if we can get the
documents there's here's rona daniel
let's listen to this pain in
coordinating this effort what did the
president say when he called you
essentially he turned the call over to
mr eastman who then
proceeded to
talk about the importance of the rnc
helping the campaign gather
these contingent electors in case any of
the legal challenges
um that were ongoing change the result
of
any of the dates
i think more just so there's ronan
mcdaniel i'm not finding the the
comparison of the electors but
it is hilarious because one looks like
it's written on a napkin or just a like
a notebook sheet of paper and then the
other
they look official like they have this i
mean the other thing too is they uh this
is also the niece of mitt romney for
people who don't know
uh
that you know it's like of course
everyone's [ __ ] tied in together
doing stuff you know and now they're all
like okay look
this is what really went down and i was
very vocal about it from the very
beginning it's like go [ __ ] right
yeah whatever that's all [ __ ] you
know we see this bowers guy this bowers
guy give his testimony which again i
thought was some of the most compelling
guess it was a very moving testimony and
then it's like how do you negate that
like
that like it's like oh [ __ ] maybe the
republican party does have morals maybe
they are someone who has [ __ ] balls
and are willing to stand up and defend
the constitution and then
in that same breath right after he goes
yeah but i'll vote for the guy if he's
the nominee right
i don't want eric greitens to come kick
in my door right he's like i'm not a
rhino right jesus which makes me think
like i don't know if you watch the chris
christie uh coverage after with abc no
huh which by the way it's like christy
but yeah why are people giving chris
christie the time of day to speak his
dumb ass [ __ ] but what he did try to do
was he tried to say oh you know the two
equal events that happened here were uh
the 2000 election and what happened with
uh um with al gore but
but also
that uh we're making the 2016 election
with hillary clinton equal in comparison
they are of equal stature and value to
what's happening with the 2020 election
and it's like no no no no no no and and
and the the correspondent the anchor
that was talking was like i just want to
call this out real quick chris christie
we are not saying that they're equal
thing he's like no no that's not what
i'm saying it's like no no but i want to
make clear for our viewers and our
listeners right now that they understand
that what you are saying is is false
they are not equal right
we didn't we didn't storm the capital
when hillary lost yeah we were [ __ ]
upset we didn't like the results and we
found out that yes there was russian
involvement in actual like influence
but we didn't try to [ __ ] threaten to
return the constitution we didn't say
hey you know what we should hang
the vice president you know hang joe
biden hang him up he would he wouldn't
he wouldn't throw the election to
hillary hang him up exactly now we
actually we actually elected him as the
next yeah that's gonna be like uh we'll
come back and we'll get it we'll get it
right the next time right right and
that's not saying that you know that's
not saying biden is perfect like he's
got his own flaws but at least he's not
trying to [ __ ] create a fascist
government dictatorship speaking
speaking of democrats being held
accountable speaking of that um andrew
gillum you remember this guy he ran
against uh ron desantis oh yeah you know
this is this is going to be this i know
this is going to be used as uh
misinformation
uh this andrew gillum stuff
uh you know i i don't know exactly what
the rights angle is going to be on this
um exactly yet i mean you can start to
guess because it's pretty easy to guess
what they're gonna do but andrew gillum
was a once uh as mark right here it was
a once rising democratic star who
narrowly lost
his 2018 gubernatorial race against ron
desantis
has told associates that he expects to
be indicted in federal court as early as
today for alleged fraud tied to his
campaign
so here we see the justice department
now remember remember the timing of this
this is this is four years ago folks
and they are just now charging andrew
gillum okay so think about that
in that of the time frame right that has
taken the department of justice
four years or more or less you know
three or four years from the time that
they probably started to collect
evidence right of this of this fraud
that is tied to his campaign to indict
him to bring it to his grand jury to
indict it now rather he'll escape the
charges or he'll prove his innocence
because in this country you are supposed
to be innocent until proven guilty
but here
just look at the timing of this so if
you're if you're looking for what the
timing of justice justices
normally in the department of justice
when you're talking about federal
elections
or state elections or federal charges on
elections
use this as a road map here andrew
gillum who's a democrat
which the department of justice should
not
select which political party should be
the one who gets indicted or not it
should not matter if a democrat's
creating or
committing election fraud the same as
republicans they should charge them but
think about this for a second
this is two years prior to 2020 and
january 6 that we're talking about a lot
right now because of these hearings and
we're just now seeing that there might
be an indictment of andrew gillum from a
grand a federal grand jury
so think about that timing if that
timing is the same
kind of timing then we would expect two
to three possibly four years to see
charges from the actual
act of the insurrection january 6 the
events leading up to it the fraud of the
big the big crime as people are calling
now and sort of the big lie or the big
rip-off yeah thank you to kfa for that
one yes the big crime
and if anyone hasn't seen the coverage
from yesterday make sure to check it out
it's on the midas touch channel uh we
have pre during the the hearing mid and
post
uh commentary and it's all yeah you can
actually go get caught up on all of
those because there's a playlist over on
the midas touch youtube channel i just
wanted to point out this andrew gillum
story because the right will say oh the
left is ignoring this no but not
if anything this just gives you a road
map of what the timing right is going to
look like for the january 6th hearings i
mean it's a lot of people a lot of
people that are like oh you know it's uh
merrick garland isn't doing his job it's
like dude give the guy
give him a second okay there is a lot of
stuff that happened previously in the
last administration we're dealing with
january 6. he's over in ukraine right
now like he has been charging people for
the crimes that they have committed but
we're talking a very
large scale coup
for this specifically that was happening
there's also a ton of other stuff you
know and they did i think it was uh
i forget when they start maybe this
summer didn't they hire like a [ __ ] ton
of new uh investigators and lawyers to
uh to join the doj
well yeah
there's a lot of evidence to comb
through with not just uh the stuff that
we're seeing in the january 6 select
committee but also the people that laid
siege on the capitol that day that were
convinced by donald trump to go actually
commit acts of violence to keep him to
be the president united states we now
are seeing that that was kind of a
distraction from the real plan that they
had which was to maybe even arrest
members of congress so that they could
get it thrown back so they could put
these fake electors right that ron
johnson is trying to hand an envelope to
the vice version slide it slide it
across the desk or something
i mean look look we all know it trump is
guilty the committee is making a very
good case for why trump knew it was
wrong was told repeatedly that it was
wrong and still went forward with it so
i just want to say for all the merrick
garland kind of people out there like
give them a sec
the committee itself is is putting
together the case they have everything
documented categorized they're getting
new evidence they are bringing it
through telling a story for people to
share and then with that the doj will
take it forward and say great we've got
everything we need right now and we
we've been following along so that we
can actually make markers say make this
case make this case make this case
instead of having all of this
evidence uh just like dumped on your
desk and saying like okay now you gotta
sift through it so right i think that's
an important thing to remember here
right well i i i know i think you have
to go and it's a shame yeah because you
gotta jump i gotta well because jim
jordan jim jordan is trending so uh
let's just no nope nope nope if you're
gonna jump off all right no
you don't have fun with this i get to
have fun with this all right i would
love for you to stick around but yeah i
know audience audience stick around no
he won't be with us he's got he's got a
special meeting he's going to go to spa
it's probably one of them george soros
cabal media it is he i'm just honestly
look the check was on like
i just had to i just have to pick up the
check no big deal oh okay well you know
the audience knows that gabe is going to
pick up his george soros chick so he
can't be joining us for the jim jordan
talk so right after this right after
this folks i'm going to go to the trendy
trends of jim jordan and show you why
he's trending it's hilarious by the way
that's why i was laughing when you were
saying something yeah not that i would
say anything funny right well right
right when you well you were saying
something serious
anyone on the youtube channel you saw me
laughing when you were saying something
serious i was reading ahead to see what
the show was going to be so everyone
stick around we will not have gabe after
this message but we will have jim jordan
we will have jim jordan and why it's so
hilarious so gabe if you're in your
meeting you can watch you can watch this
yeah i'll giggle to myself okay great
all right everyone stick around we will
be right back with why jim jordan is
trending it's hilarious stick around
we'll be right back right after these
messages see you later gabe
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
[Music]
through the break we're about to find
out why jim jordan is trending
on twitter hilarious
this is this is exactly the reason why
nancy pelosi was like no you're not
going to be on the [ __ ] select
committee piece of trash
because he does trashy [ __ ] things
jim jordan because he's a piece of
[ __ ] trash
jim i don't report sex crimes jordan
apparently the george clooney uh
documentary's supposed to drop i don't
know when that thing's supposed to drop
but we're gonna find out just how much
of a scumbag this guy is i mean we know
he's a scumbag but we're really gonna
find out in this documentary but let's
go to why jim jordan is trending on
twitter uh aaron reports here jim
jordan's question for roger goodell now
roger goodell if you don't know is the
the nfl commissioner he's the head of
the nfl he's the guy that decides all
the he's the he's the king he's the
commando right
he asked he asked him some questions
about dave portnoy i don't know if you
guys knew dave portnoy is but this guy's
a [ __ ] joke he's a weirdo that's
right all you stoolies out there i said
it dayton portnoy is a dumb [ __ ] he's a
complete dumb [ __ ]
any he he's interviewed trump he's a
trumper he's a he's a [ __ ]
he's an inselled crybaby white dude who
likes to give pizza or burger reviews or
some [ __ ]
any
he pretends he knows about sports or
something
but here here there jim jordan is asking
about this chucklehead to the
commissioner of the nfl now that
remember this is an official hearing
this isn't like some kind of [ __ ]
talk over beers
this is an official hearing in congress
listen to this recognize thank you madam
chair commissioner uh you believe in the
first amendment here we go
we do
i mean all parts of it all all you know
all rights we have you're right to
practice your faith your right to
petition the government right to
assemble
again i think this committee hearing the
reason board is the um
is the name of the washington the new
washington
uh football team you know they were the
washington redskins for years
and people found it offensive and they
end up changing their name but i think
that's what the hearing's about here but
jim jordan is making this about freedom
of speech
freedom of speech
but let's listen freedom of press
freedom of speech you you believe in all
that he doesn't jim jordan doesn't roger
dale may claim to why do you ban dave
portnoy from nfl games
[Laughter]
okay okay okay okay so here we have here
we have jim jordan
he can ask the nfl commissioner anything
he wants about the freedom of speech and
the freedom of the press for that matter
and he chooses
to ask
the nfl commissioner why dave portnoy
isn't at nfl games
what the [ __ ]
pardon me i couldn't hear your question
why do you ban dave portnoy from nfl
games
he's a journalist in fact he's a
sports journalist why is he banned
that's a loose term sports journalist
that's a loose term i mean that's like
calling me a journalist i'm not a
journalist
i'm not a journalist i'm not
dave portnoy is not a journalist he's a
commentator and a clown
uh congressman i'm not familiar with
that uh issue i'm happy to check with my
staff but i'm aware of that as if the
nfl commissioner sits around really
worrying
rather rather one dude is is gonna go
report
and commentate on sports events like one
dude that's what you're worried about
yes
well i think i think we're all aware
we're all aware of that i mean he
interviewed
interviewed the president united states
oh my god he interviewed the clown
president donald trump holy [ __ ]
well let's [ __ ] ring a bell for him
interviewed president trump in the white
house it seems to me if you can get into
the white house you should be able to
get into a football game hey listen
listen listen jim jordan there was a lot
of people who got into the trump white
house who should not have been in there
a lot of russians a lot of a lot of
politicians
a lot of a lot of traitors that were in
that white house like i don't know
enrique tario sydney powell michael
flynn get the [ __ ] out of here with this
nonsense just because you were invited
into the trump white house makes you
some kind of it gives gives you some
kind of [ __ ] legitimacy bull [ __ ]
[ __ ] it actually does the opposite in my
book particularly as a member of the
press and a member of the sports press
you know anything about that
jim jordan seems to think he's got like
a gotcha moment here now this is this is
all for the stoolies
right because jim jordan knows that this
documentary is coming out about it where
he was he was a he was a coach at a
university and he looked the other way
when young men were being sexually
assaulted he knew about it and he looked
the other way he wouldn't report the sex
crimes and as a matter of fact he tried
to cover up those crimes after the fact
begging those people and i think that's
what we're going to see in this in this
[ __ ] documentary once it comes out
we're going to know the [ __ ]
george clooney's been working on this
thing we're gonna know the truth about
jim jordan
and so he's trying to rally the [ __ ]
white and cell bar stoolies out there if
you don't know who dave portnoy is this
[ __ ] is the is the head of
barstool sports or some [ __ ]
and they're called stoolies you know the
trolls and the comments that you see
sometimes they're stoolies
they're stoolies i mean sometimes
they're they're white nationalists and
sometimes
they're trump humpers
sometimes they're stoolies but when you
put a venn diagram of that together
it starts to kind of look like a [ __ ]
circle right
and that's who he's talking to that's
you jim i don't report sex crimes jordan
is talking to
is he's talking to the [ __ ] troll
stoolies
because he knows what's about to happen
so he has to create this army of
stoolies and he's doing that with an
official proceeding
asking the nfl commissioner
about dave portnoy who he claims as a
journalist because he talked to trump or
he did an interview with trump if you
think anyone who does an interview with
trump if that's automatically makes you
a journalist you have not been paying
the [ __ ] tension
you have not been paying attention you
don't sir
do you agree with the washington
redskins decision to find jack del rio a
hundred thousand dollars
that was the decision that was made by
coach rivera uh again as i stated
earlier uh they are responsible for
monitoring and
managing their own workplace he made
that decision on his own i did not speak
to him i have great respect for coach
rivera uh he made this decision for
reasons i'm sure that he thought were
uh but i i appreciate all of you
i appreciate all that commissioner but
that's not what i ask you i said do you
agree with the washington redskins
decision to find jack del rio a hundred
thousand dollars
i i don't think it's my position to be
able to say whether uh it was the
correct decision or not well mr do uh
coach rivera in his
statement when he find his assistant
coach
okay i i can't i can't [ __ ] i can't
handle this it's just [ __ ] box anymore i
get in all this [ __ ] box anymore i can't
do it anymore i'm gonna tweet it if you
want to watch the rest of the [ __ ]
the nonsense there
i'll retweet it aaron's video here and
you can go you can go watch
you'll watch the rest of jim jordan
the fact of the matter is is that during
a [ __ ] hearing with the commissioner
of the the nfl
jim jordan
makes clips for the stoolies he's making
he's making troll content is what he's
doing because he's a [ __ ] troll he's
a troll on our democracy
and jim i don't report sex crimes jordan
i believe
is a little a little scared
and that's why he's creating troll
content
for the trolls for the trolls let's go
back to the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends here let's see what else is going
on let's see if there's any more
breaking news here what else is trending
again andrew gillum is moving up the the
uh the polls here as he's at number two
uh roger goodell is number four because
of this um
this kind this this uh house hearing on
the probe of the commanders
now we see jewel i don't know if you
guys
i've seen this jewel is a uh e-cigarette
company i i'm not gonna go into this
thread but i find this interesting julie
uh e-cigarettes this is according to the
wall street journal here could be
ordered off the u.s market by the fda as
soon as today people familiar say um you
know there was a push to remove
e-cigarettes
uh from the market the reason why i
bring this up is because um you know
katie porter kind of went at the
consumer protection part of our laws and
that's the reason why we can take jewel
e-cigarettes
off the market with the fda's because of
consumer protection laws
and protecting consumers but we can't do
it with guns because the concern with
the e-cigarettes you remember trump
trump did this oh my god they're trying
to sell e-cigarettes in the flavor of
cherry and grape and it's killing our
children well there's [ __ ] guns
killing our children do something
[ __ ]
how about that
uh powell is trending at number seven
now you know jerome powell is the the
chairman of the federal reserve um
and prepared remarks the washington repo
reports
and uh from powell saying inflation has
obviously surprised to the upside over
to the upside over the past year
and that's russia's invasion of ukraine
post-covered related
locks in china is putting more pressure
on prices we know there's a lot of
pressure from prices in a lot of
different places now one of the most key
things that we can do here in this
country if we get our politicians to
[ __ ] and do it and to pressure them to
do it instead of blaming gas prices on
one [ __ ] we actually realize
who's at fault here um some of the
gouging that is happening is coming from
the oil companies they have record
profits right now why americans suffer
at the pump it's not biden's fault it's
not congress's fault it's not the
legislators fault it's not the court's
fault
it's
because
it's because the oil companies are
gouging us to a degree is the reason why
gas prices are the way that they are
right now and until american plucks
their head out of their ass
and starts blaming the appropriate
people for the gouging that is happening
the [ __ ] president united states
isn't gouging anyone there's no
gasoline button in the oval office folks
there's only so much the president and
the legislator can do
now
when they do pass a bill to try to curb
gouging republicans who are the ones
bitching the most about the price of gas
and blaming it on biden vote against it
that's right they vote against lowering
the gas prices by going after gouging
from the big oil companies
sounds more like bowers talk here bowers
trending at number 14 you know
at the top of the show i talked about
how
rusty bowers the republican arizona
house speaker
capitulated to trump yesterday after he
was not under oath anymore yeah i'd vote
for the guy sure i'd vote for the trader
absolutely the guy who pressured me and
threatened my family you goddamn right
i'd vote for him it's really [ __ ]
stupid
ohio state university is trending
um d is now trademarked in the united
states
okay
marco rubio is trending because he voted
against the
advancement of the bipartisan gun safety
bill in the senate we know that there
was uh 14 senators with mitch mcconnell
surprisingly voting to advance the
debate of the language
of the gun safety bill uh my question to
marco rubio and let me let me go to that
let me see if i can find that here real
quick my question to marco rubio was
pretty pointed here about his vote um
about the gun safety bill because
there's red flag laws in there and
that's one of the reasons why
marco decided to vote against it
um was oh well
you can't do that the nra pays me a
bunch of money to capitulate
so here here i asked marco rubio i said
how does gqp like marco rubio think
he'll survive eric greitens rhino
hunting season
how do you think you're gonna survive
that marco
how do you think what do you think you
think you think you think the uh eric
greitens of the world is gonna come hunt
you down yes son of a [ __ ] that's the
truth and then that's what they're doing
it's rhino hunting season
that's what eric greitens says
and they're all being called rhinos this
morning by other republicans i don't
call [ __ ] republicans rhinos they're
not rhinos name only they're fascist
they're fascists
eric greitens is a fascist trump is a
fascist rusty bowers is a fascist
that's right folks i said it
he loves what trump did he loves what
trump did he just didn't want to go to
prison for trump that's it that's it
that's all that's all he didn't want to
go to prison for trump that's it
that's it
he just didn't want to go to prison for
trump
and in that case yeah he couldn't he
couldn't break his oath because if he
broke his oath
might end up in federal prison
like major maybe gillum will
for breaking federal election laws
it's a thing
law enforcement department of justice
it's a thing
and it prevented
rusty bowers
from doing that uh let's see what else
do oh we oh woke is trending
so is george clooney um let's go to to
woke oh my god
woke this trending
whoosh
uh
you know that the the senator from
louisiana
john kennedy
coined the phrase woker
and we love the phrase woker here george
clooney is also trending here
um it's probably for the the film that
is going to come out for ohio state
university um let's see is there news on
this
oh it lands it at george clooney's
ohio state abuse documentary lands at
hbo
looks like hbo is going to carry the
documentary now that may be the news
here
um
let's see if we can find some official
official report of when this thing drops
the hollywood reporters is reporting
this
that the george clooney ohio state abuse
documentary lands at hbo again you know
that that documentary
is
in response to the scandal
uh the jim jordan i jim i don't rep
report sex kind jordan scandal um here
is the article here
let's go back let's see
i i thought hollywood reporter would
have this thing going
i want to go see if i have some more
video i had some more video i want to
show you guys i almost forgot we got 10
minutes to go here
in the show
now before we leave
and i have some more video
i know i had some morbidity yes uh ted
lou ted lou talks about that as talking
about republicans and what they do
here's a good video from ted lou and
it's real short real to the point
let's listen to dead
democrats are for the people
and we put people over politics we also
pass an infrastructure law that's going
to rebuild roads bridges and highways
get let out of water and put broadband
everywhere from rural areas to inner
cities and everywhere in between what
are republicans doing
well i don't know
but i know a number of republican
members of congress
sought a pardon from the white house for
inciting an insurrection
i don't know what the hell they're doing
tedlu
but it really does seem like they're
getting into the pardon line
to me
oh who
who can't loves them from ted lou
um he's fantastic he's fantastic oh i
wanted to show you this keith oberman
tweeted this um i don't usually show uh
as keith says here [ __ ] and he calls
donald trump [ __ ] [ __ ] can't
spell stolen that was trending earlier
let alone provide an atom of evidence um
and trump put out a statement on true
social you know it's [ __ ] lies if
it's over there especially if it's not
hidden um the highly partisan unselects
oh my god that's what he's calling him
the highly partisan unselects the
unselects
are trying to create a fake narrative
now here's the thing
this guy's upset
at what that kevin mccarthy didn't allow
his his [ __ ] lackeys to be on this
committee there was there was an
opportunity
for kevin mccarthy to to put people on
this committee
it's a bipartisan select committee
but he refused he refused
and then when he wanted to put people
who were complicit in the scheme to
overturn the constitution of the united
states nancy pelosi said no you got to
pick some serious [ __ ] not jim
i don't report sex crimes jordan he
won't even report sex crimes on children
what what the [ __ ] do you think how the
[ __ ] do you think he's gonna report
these crimes get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ]
nancy pelosi dunk that [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] trash
but kevin mccarthy had a chance to to
have their own narrative inside the
select committee
this bonehead says they're trying to
create a fake narrative you trying to
create fake narrative dummy
for whatever reason trump says but only
with evil intention evil
evil intention
that he me
he knew he it's hard to read this folks
it really is hard to read this
he lost the election this is completely
false what he's saying here is
him losing election is completely false
which we know that to be
a categorically a [ __ ] lie after
yesterday's testimony
two states two states arizona and
georgia
right if you just go and i believe this
is what the select committee is doing
here if you just take those two states
and and go at the word of the people who
were under oath yesterday which you
should
just know that those two states put joe
biden over the top
like just those two states
and all the other states that were
certified that were questioned by donald
trump personally
in arizona and georgia because he really
wasn't looking for someone to overturn
the election for him he was looking for
for a evidence for mike pence to do it
give him some kind of fodder you know
cannon fodder to come
to keep
grifting and keep selling the big lie
and the big crime
the [ __ ] goes on to say here i felt the
election was rigged and stolen
stolen apparently is a uh is a german
fruitcake which makes a lot of sense
here
right makes a lot of sense that he would
he's he misspelled stolen
s-t-o-l-l-e-n is way spelled i don't
like to make fun of people who misspell
i misspell people point it out
i'm i i don't spell that will and
sometimes my spell check doesn't work
that great i don't give a [ __ ]
and neither does
chief [ __ ] here grandpa poopy pants
the cheeto dust mobster
but stolen stolen i think i don't know
how you say in german
s-t-o-l-l-e-n if you look it up it's a
german fruit cake with for you know it's
a cake it's a fruitcake with fruits and
nuts in it it's nuttier than squirrel
turds
which is appropriate in what he's saying
here
[Laughter]
in his freudian misspelling um he goes
on to say have from the very beginning
and have only gotten stronger in that
belief with time and large amounts of
additional evidence approved what he's
saying is i've convinced more and more
people that i got the election stolen
from me because of my propaganda that's
what he's saying
in my mind i have and have no question
to many people blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah
continues to [ __ ] his diapers down at
mar-a-lago
continues to [ __ ] his diapers and that's
more sign of this here
and i love that keith olbermann called
him out on this i don't like to post his
statements but this one really seems
like a little scared animal doesn't it i
mean yesterday he put out a statement to
rusty bowers who says he'll even he'll
even vote for donald trump again
basically threatening him to lie under
oath telling him this is what you should
say rusty bowers that's basically what
he said
and we and i i plan on
um
i i think michael cohen's gonna join us
tomorrow for the hearing which you guys
should go over the link is available
right now on the midas touch youtube
channel go over as soon as the show's
over we got a few more minutes as soon
as you leave here stay on youtube go
over
subscribe to the minus touch youtube
channel and reset your reminder for
tomorrow's hearing
because that is very important
super important
because i i hope to i hope michael cohen
joins us again he's joined us a few
times during these hearings because i
want to ask him about that actual
statement that trump put out to rusty
bowers i want to see if he believes it's
the same thing i'm seeing it was a
threat lie or else
that's what he said i think that's what
he was saying lie or else i'm going to
ask michael cohen that tomorrow
in the hearings so here's what's going
to happen i'm on that's super important
we're going to do our show live just
like we do noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific on youtube twitter twitch and
simulcast from the midas touch facebook
page
i'm gonna have to end the podcast about
15 minutes early so we're only gonna do
about two
and three quarters hour on the podcast
tomorrow
unfortunately because i gotta have 15
minutes to get set up
for the hearings
i'm gonna be broadcasting live
for probably six maybe seven hours
depending on how long these hearings are
tomorrow i will be with you live here on
our channel on the midas touch facebook
page and midas touch youtube channel so
don't forget to see where i'm going to
be at tomorrow
follow me around i'll try to tweet it
out and get you the links but here's
what you gotta do tomorrow be here on
our channel
youtube twitter twitch and the minus
touch facebook page for the show
at noon eastern 11 central nine pacific
the tony michaels podcast i will air
live
and then and we will talk a lot about
the hearing and some of the news that's
going on because i'm sure there'll be
more news tomorrow about the hearing
and then
after the show we will end about 15
minutes early
to uh to get set up for the hearings so
go over to the minus touch our facebook
page go over to the youtube page go to
their twitter page that link is there
for that hearing
make sure to go set a reminder for that
link
for the hearing tomorrow day five
and join us tomorrow for the entirety of
the hearing we will do commentary an
hour before we will do commentary at a
break if we get one and we will also do
a commentary afterwards with a panel of
guests
so please come join us tomorrow
and make sure to catch our commentary we
have some new commentary from some new
guests tomorrow you're not gonna want to
miss that oh you're not going to want to
miss some of our guests from tomorrow
you will not want to miss that
so make sure to follow us here on the
tony michaels podcast subscribe to our
youtube channel
so you don't miss a single thing and
download every single episode of the
tony michaels podcast on apple spotify
google and your favorite directories
everywhere
also tomorrow you know it's thursday so
we will be putting out the bonehead of
the week poll so go follow us at
tonymichaelspot on twitter we will put
the bonehead of the week poll there
tomorrow i'm sure i'm sure there's going
to be plenty of boneheads that are going
to merge tomorrow after the hearings
but again right now right now once i'm
about to end this broadcast once i end
this broadcast go over to the midas
touch youtube channel subscribe and make
sure to set a reminder
for the hearing tomorrow which again our
coverage starts at 2
pm eastern
time
which is exactly the time that we end
this broadcast you know that because
you're right here with me right now in
that moment so tomorrow we'll have to
end just a little early to get set up
for the hearings so don't forget to come
watch us tomorrow at noon eastern 11
central nine pacific right here on
youtube twitter twitch simulcasting from
the midas touch facebook page the tony
michaels podcast and then we will
produce day five of the hearing tomorrow
on the minus touch youtube channel go
click that link set your reminder until
tomorrow
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking